The Joe Rogan Experience yeah as opposed
to something like NBC or CBS or ABC
which is like probably standard
operational procedure right to like have
people pay to put Coca-Cola on right
because they need to make money however
they can because they're on competition
with Amazon and with Netflix they're
going to come to you with Bud Light
there you go you guys can fix Bud Light
I saw a new one today did you see the
Miller Lite one today yeah like did just
no one learned does no one learn I mean
and they were taking all those ads that
we loved from the 80s and they're just
put them in shredders that was their
campaign today I saw it this morning
it's so stupid I mean it I don't know
but like there's something wrong also
it's making there's something wrong with
women wearing bikinis those women wear
bikinis because they look great they
like to look great they take photos of
them looking great the girls see those
photos of them in bikinis they get
excited look I look great people buy it
wow she looks great
it's not bad to look great it's just
like it's not bad for a guy to have a
shirt off yeah if Chris Pratt has his
shirt off and he's looking ripped it's
not objectifying I mean I guess it is
but it's not negative
selling movie tickets right there that
that ad is so weird isn't it strange you
want to watch it let's watch it we just
watch it oh boy here we go I couldn't
believe it this morning they don't learn
no one learns well it's just in general
I think it's kind of those taking
lessons from the past and applying them
going forward as wisdom how about
lessons from a week ago I know it's not
even the past it's like a couple days
ago the only thing that saves is like
maybe they spent a lot of money on it
and they've filmed it six months ago is
that possible already still yeah there's
an article from two months but still you
could put a pause on that oh it came out
two months ago at least two months ago
okay so it came out before the [__]
right was that about the same time as
the [__]
it was this says it was an honor of
women's history month that's why I put
it out so I'm like I was I saw it today
I was like maybe there's a reason they
made this and we just started seeing it
but it's also crazy they want to shred
all the good looking pictures from the
80s and they're buying it back that was
part of the thing they're buying back
all the those old ads that people have I
guess in their garage walls that's what
it said in the this thing that I saw
this morning oh God and they're going to
turn it into like yeah that's it first
to brew beer ever from Mesopotamia to
the middle they're saying women brewed
beer they said they were the first we're
the ones doing the Brewing centuries
later how did the industry pay homage to
the founding mothers of beer they put us
in bikinis with awesome pictures like
that as hell she looks hot yeah
I mean look at that those are great
those are great ads
it's kind of beer made it up to women so
today Miller Lite is
really lights on a mission to make sure
no one buys their stuff
oh my goodness I'm buying it back so
that he can turn it into it for women
Brewers they're scouring the internet
buying it back yeah ladies because
that's easy to do once you get an image
up there on the internet so what is she
saying it's a compost to warps
beautiful fertilizer uh that's
interesting helps Farmers grow quality
hops yeah which has been donated to
women Brewers to make their own really
good
but there's definitely more [__] out
there in your attic in the garage in
your parents basement send any [__] you
got into Miller Lite and they'll turn
that into good [__] too
oh
so here's to women because without us
there would be no fear
wow oh God I hate identity politics with
a passion I really do it's pretty
interesting it's so stupid it's human
beings made beer okay
and some human beings look good in
bikinis it's like what are we doing it's
crazy women do it women do it women do
it I'd like to see a pie chart of how
many women are actually involved in
making beer or drinking beer well now
I'm gonna hold on to all those posters
from Miller Lite that I have from the
80s in my garage I'm gonna turn that
stuff in it's gonna be worth a lot more
now do you have some no I can imagine I
wish I could go all those years did
Miller Lite ads with their [__] yeah no
I mean that was crazy to wake up I mean
to see that this morning can you does
paper turn into compost is that how it
works I mean is it a bunch of chemicals
and [__] why are they lying to us why
would something like that just get
resurfaced on like a Monday and now
everyone's talking because people are
angry they're looking to be angry too
much that's what I mean like it's been
out for two months we didn't see it
before that I think the Bud Light thing
was probably so overwhelming that no one
paid attention to anything else yeah and
now that that's kind of died down